now this time we're doing things a
little differently and I mean
differently time to get changed now when
people know I'm coming they all tend to
be on their best Bloody Behavior so I'm
going under cover to catch all of them
off
guard in order to blend in I've invited
four local musicians to camouflage me
going undercover sounds amazing ready
for lunch yeah let's
go hi how yall doing hi hi Minnie five
of us five you can put them in there
over here excuse me hello guys how are
you let me get you a serber we look how
busy that street is out there how can a
restaurant fail so miserably with so on
door businesses on either side of this
are
packed you decided have the flly chicken
please we're ordering classic New
Orleans dishes the eggs Jonathan
crawfish boy that any restaurant in The
Big Easy should be able to perfect thank
you gentlemen
well Band-Aids I just cut the [__] out
my the red fish even the
Crawfish is that a red
fish it's funny how all the three
waitresses are standing in the
bar you got it girl yeah
baby weird it's frozen but it don't
smell bad probably good all right I
think it's time to change my bandid it's
I think it was bleeding through
it it's been a minute
huh what happened put a wrong
pleas excuse
me man' think you can hear
me Jesus too busy
man' throwing [__] on the floor ah ah
screwed it up thank you the red fish
redish thank
you man toast looks pretty burn when a
restaurant can't get [__] toast right
uh you know we're [__]
mhm how do you like your eggs
man not sure yet EG is rock out in the
center not good not
good thank you so much
so I've got rotten
fries let's SW the
chicken chicken smells funny I don't
know what they've done to
them please don't eat anymore what I've
discovered in the kitchen is pretty
gross and what I'm about to show you in
a couple minutes is Rockin I've seen
enough excuse MH I'm
problem I've never seen anything that
bad ever and the atmosphere was
terrible it smells in there it's like
the restaurant's given up and no one
gives a
[Music]
[__] right time to take the family want
tell him who's hungry I us let's go this
disguise pays homage to one of my
favorite comedies stinks stinks the
National Lampoon Vacation
movies is this
legle this is great hopefully our meal
is less disastrous than some of their
vacations oh
man here we go some macaronis how are
you hey can we get a table of four
please sure right this way when you walk
into bana's your first instinct is to
walk right back out set them on table 23
please I'm sorry 43 how depressing is
this Decor the tacky decor and the
uninviting staff makes you feel
immediately unwelcome you need a few
minutes or are you ready no um nope what
nope we're ready nope we need a few
minutes okay can we order gamari FR
we've ordered a variety of classic
Italian dishes and spaghetti meatballs
very good I'll be right back thank you
if you can't do these staples properly
fried kamati baked Lamb's chop first
then a family [__] salad you have no
business being in the restaurant
business I have the two appetizers yeah
go
ahead go for it so this is that's the
bank clams take one and say a prayer
let's see what I've got in mind
then clams are really salty no it tastes
like I'm eating just breadcrumbs I had
no clam in mine either so clam with no
clam did you get a
clam calamari is rubbery it's not even
crispy it taste old if you like I can
give you a little on each of your dish
if you want these clams are horrendous
okay there is not a clam in okay there
I'd be more than happy to take them off
the trck there you got it whatever he
wants hello yes clam sucked Hey listen
you got to stop okay I clam suck my
sister sucks got to stop cuz it's
[__] [__] you hear that shouting
no don't clams in the clams no nothing
there's no clam in the clam whatever
that's why they ate the whole [__]
thing yeah I know yeah okay tip it up
you can cook yourself yeah you got cook
yourself yeah I know cuz I'm the one
saying this I'm making it up know
customer doesn't like yeah look at my
salad this salad is appalling look it's
dead don't eat the uh dressing smell
like the back seat of my car spaghetti
meatballs eggplant
F so let's say a little prayer for the
Onre the Lord prepared for receive may
we not end up in ER thank you
that is horrendous oh my God oh my God
that looks like the inside of my
grandfather's Underpants that looks like
a placenta I would not feed this to my
dog I would do it this is horrendous do
tremendous meaning you want me to take
it away you didn't like it dear it was
horrible okay great take it away Daniel
please you know what if you like the
whole din is on me enjoy okay okay well
you don't have to be nasty dear you
don't like anything you don't have to be
nasty I'm not nasty at all dear
thank you wow is he always like that is
he always he always
angry oh my lord it's like they're
scared of him he said the ve sucked the
eggplant sucked this sucked everything
sucks so it's [__] [__] I'm done
so [__] done it's [__] [__]
see you in a minute not see enough I'll
please thank you where's Daniel you know
what why don't you buy them coffee and
dessert too so they complain about that
too tell them it's on me everything cuz
I food sucks cuz it's [__] [__]
holy [__]
[__] oh man that was absolutely
shocking man when people know I'm coming
they all tend to be on their best Bloody
Behavior so I'm going under cover to
catch all of them off
[Music]
guard right time for out of the time
good evening guys today I'm getting
together with some friends from the
neighborhood let's go to blend in with
the locals so I can get the inside scoop
on The Brownstone Beast
stro yo yo yo yo yo yo good to see you
guys um there is no presence in the
dining room no host no manager no
greeting it's
terrible we're ordering classic carine
dishes that any authentic Jamaican
restaurant should be able to do yeah can
we get the lobster mac and cheese please
okay so lobster mac and cheese The Jerk
wings for the whole table and the jerk
Wings also I'll do the grilled goodbye
the ox okay great okay coming up okay no
they don't look in love with their job
no do they
no dig in oh my Wing's cold in the
middle when a restaurant can't get a
wing right it doesn't hold up much for
the Entre it and where in the [__] is
the lobster and the cheese looks like
it's been sprayed out of a can it does
not look fresh at all um oxs right here
thank you and I'm going to watch y'all
all eat no where's yours just a moment
youby coming
up [__]
is Let's Get Married with
this somebody SP
Tire Man
I've had enough it's time to get out
this disguise and get to
work oh my
Lord that was pretty bad oh my
goodness time to get
changed since I'm in the heart of the
Delta I've decided to disguise myself as
the lifeblood of this country an
American
[Music]
Farmer guys hey yeah you ready man on
the table yes let's do it you let's
cover it let's go let
St it's time for a big old plate of that
famous Southern
Hospitality we going to kind of take a
little break before we start up at night
I'm not sure um I sure do need it place
looks like a do with a paint no yeah the
farmers I'm with are locals which should
help me maintain my cover hey there how
are y'all but after spotting the Hideous
decor I'm feeling a tad over Dressed Man
time you smell that huh what's that
smell like I waste that some stinks in
this kitchen I ain't just going to tell
y'all the truth I don't know what it is
but it's some stank my feet are sticking
to the [__] carpet have I just
stepped in HSE man holy
[__] well let's test drive the Flaming y
that's the best I have to offer meat and
ters what's a tater a tater
potato oh
potato we're ordering menu items that
should be Southern Staples let me get
the bowl of the gumbo the fried oysters
can I get a side pork chop I'm going to
try the uh fried catfish Bel I with the
large fillet flounder flounder
mhm thank you
ma'am Bean Lo was here would you come
here we quit coming here about 3 years
ago going down
here bring me your appetizers are up
that's look kind of
sad
[Music]
yes thank you Jesus Christ look at that
greasy
rubbery gumb man I'm going to pass on
the
gumbo there oers sh
oh good that's a little chewy it feels
like I'm chewing a [__] golf pear
don't swallow that way St a stu ra
fer stiny fish FY fish
sanky
hey look at that oh my
Lord stuffing on top of that smells
catch the day Hepatitis
B little catfish for my
oh my Lord you think the catfish would
be exceptional wouldn't
you that is terrible taste of that it
looks like it oh that's horrible right
there man that's not good I'm going to
going get changed okay so just uh just
try and attend to eat please do Cuz I'm
not real sure how long I can keep eating
this
seriously that was shocking food is
embarrassing flounder oh my Lord it was
[__]
Grim time to go sightseing morning guys
we
good smile please everybody Madam
play I'm posing as a French tourist so I
can go deep undercover I lived in Paris
for 3 years D on doe two years I learned
to speak French whilst training as a
chef in Paris in my early days so this
was the perfect
opportunity also on your right Fox
Studios home to The Simpsons new girl
and me I have a pretty good idea where
we'll go for lunch all right well look
it looks like one of my favorite
restaurants laata let's see if they'll
let us join in the fun guys all right
thank you hopefully I won't be
spotted all right we got customers
welcome to last you guys great great
thank you we got n coming in
miss this place looks great
pleas see we are ordering dishes that
any Mexican restaurant worth their
margaritas and salt should be able to
make I'll have
the we'll have that I'll have I okay
very good one more thing yeah we have
the breakfast uh burrito thank you
having seen the practices in that
kitchen from my surveillance
team look at this I'm not expecting
much oh [__] was last time this thing
saw liquor paint really
really so we should P
down
swe for deols
yeah oh the sweat came off his [__]
nose into my suit I look look at that
it's spilling over like a
volcano what does it taste like that
tastes
[Music]
disgusting okay
burrito burrito thank you okay for the
okay you have to make everybody happy
every single people has to be happy with
the food
I don't think the food's a problem
here that is gross I'm not going to tell
you what that reminds me of it's like
the inside of my great granddad's
Underpants without the
pain okay Mahi with the garlic I think
you're the Mahi lady aren you it's here
no he's here you don't like spicy right
I that's me I'm the no spicy lady okay
I'm the one who who ordered my HEI just
put the plate down okay there you go so
this is a salmon no that's mahi mahi Mah
Mah it's the same it's the same yours
spicy yours is the chili thingies and
mine is the mild one oh my
goding rude no composure it's just
running around like a headless chicken
right I've seen enough thank you I'll be
back in a moment okay see you
later wow so that was shocking service
is Dreadful food is embarrassing you can
feel the panic in everyone that this
place is sinking and more
importantly everyone's given up if I'm
going to help this Kine friendly place
I'm going have to get in there and start
sniffing around so I need to go
Incognito to truly assess the
situation
Callie hi guys how are we good to see
you
[Music]
good girl sit sit good girl today I'm
heading to lunch with my fellow dog
lovers and our furry friends to see how
rough things really
are oh man come on Carly hey come on
Mojo like this one hello there
hi did you notice when we came in
there's no structure no rules do can be
on or off the leash they didn't tell us
anything wow I there dog's outr over the
place that dog over there is eating off
the table mhm do you all need a few more
minutes to look it over I think we're
ready for her I want the fur balls we're
ordering dog friendly Chow for a k9
companions we would like the tummy rub
surprise and American Classics for
ourselves chicken fried chicken and a
burger medium R thank you the servers
come to the table and pet the dog
mhm if you're going to have a dog
friendly restaurant they need to be
prets where you follow strict guidelines
how are you doing Sue good good good
deal all right Tracy here's your dog
bowls they'll be hot I'll take
them going to assume this small one is
for the okay fur balls thank you wow put
the dog food on the table Steam coming
off of these just touch that the that's
piping hot the P do would blend his M
yes
ridiculous you're all over it huh hey
man don't say nothing to me shut shut
you're not perfect I didn't say I was
y'all stay down there I got all this
over here I can't do this with a bunch
of people over in my area look at this
somebody make it not I just made it and
it just went
everywhere why do you make it wrong sry
here comes our food
see I'll take one of those did you about
get a by to that
Mojo I mean at this stage the dog food
looks way more trative than the
customer's food
Dreadful hello I need a burger special
just a burger you want fries sell me a
fry oh
Lord seey now SI last from be B look at
it it's gray it's white
not good not good the rest can't get a
burger ready we're in trouble that's
gross my
Lord look at
that is
that this chicken is Bland it is dry and
the gravy is shocking thank you oh my
lord it's like someone's being shot oh
my God and there's a black here it
doesn't even belong to my dog oh my Lord
what is that it's right there oh it's on
the
front that's a human hair actually look
you can even see where it came off of
her head there is everywhere the food
yes how are you look at you you so
pretty and who is this one this is Cece
Cece yes well my F's dog is named CeCe
but it's stands for Christmas cookies
oh well you guys thanks for coming out
appreciate it man
wow there's more hair in my food than
you just put on my chin a that's
terrible